reptando con manos y rodillas,
entramos a la nave, de a uno a la vez,
abriéndonos camino, reptando,
hasta desplomarnos en los asientos,
de espalda.
Se cierra la escotilla
y, de repente,
toda una vida de sueños y negaciones
se vuelve real,
algo que soñé,
de hecho, algo que elegí a los 9 años,
de pronto ahora está a unos minutos
de ocurrir de verdad.
En el mundo de los astronautas,
el transbordador es un vehículo muy complicado;
es la máquina voladora más complicada de la historia.
Y en astronáutica tenemos un dicho, que es:
"Ningún problema es tan malo
que no pueda ser peor".
(Risas)
Por eso uno está muy consciente en la cabina;
uno piensa todas estas cosas
que puede tener que hacer,
todos los interruptores y ventanillas a atender.
Y conforme se acerca el momento,
la emoción se agiganta.
Y unos 3 minutos y medio antes del lanzamiento,
las enormes toberas de la parte posterior,
del tamaño de grandes campanas,
se bambolean
y su masa es tal
que hacen balancear a todo el vehículo,
como si el vehículo estuviese vivo debajo de uno,
como si un elefante de rodillas se levantase o algo así.
Y luego unos 30 segundos antes del lanzamiento
el vehículo está completamente vivo
-- listo para salir --
las APUs están funcionando,
las computadoras autocontenidas,
listas para dejar el planeta.
Y 15 segundos antes del lanzamiento, ocurre esto:
(Video) Voz: 12, 11, 10,
9, 8, 7, 6...
(Transbordador preparado para el despegue)
... inicio, 2, 1,
ignición de propulsor, y despegue del transbordador espacial Discovery,
de vuelta a la Estación Espacial, allanando el camino...
(Transbordador despegando)
Chris Hadfield: Es increíblemente poderoso
estar a bordo una de estas cosas.
Uno está en algo
mucho más poderoso que sí mismo.
Uno tiembla tanto que no se puede concentrar
en los instrumentos que tiene en frente.
Es como si uno estuviera en las fauces de un perro enorme
y como si un pie en la parte baja de la espalda
nos empujara al espacio,
acelerando violentamente hacia arriba,
catapultándonos por el aire,
y uno está en un lugar muy complejo...
prestando atención, viendo el vehículo
pasar por cada una de sus etapas
con una sonrisa cada vez mayor en la cara.
Luego de dos minutos, esos cohetes sólidos se disparan
y luego están los motores líquidos,
el hidrógeno y el oxígeno,
y es como si uno estuviese en un auto
con el pie en el suelo,
acelerando como si nunca hubiera acelerado.
Uno se vuelve más y más liviano,
la fuerza contra uno es cada vez más fuerte.
Es como si
alguien estuviese vertiendo cemento sobre uno.
Hasta que por fin,
después de cerca de 8 minutos y 40 segundos más o menos,
por fin estamos exactamente a la altura correcta,
exactamente la velocidad adecuada,
la dirección correcta, el motor apagado,
y estamos sin peso.
Y estamos vivos.
Es una experiencia increíble.
Pero ¿por qué asumimos ese riesgo?
¿Por qué hacer algo tan peligroso?
En mi caso la respuesta es bastante sencilla.
Desde joven sentí la inspiración
de que era lo que quería hacer.
Vi a las primeras personas caminar en la luna
y, para mí, fue algo obvio;
quiero de algún modo participar en eso.
Pero la verdadera pregunta es:
¿cómo lidiar con ese peligro
y con el miedo que conlleva?
¿Cómo lidiar con el miedo versus el peligro?
Y tener el objetivo en mente, pensando a dónde podría conducir,
me llevó a una vida
de atención a los pequeños detalles que permitieran
hacer esto posible,
a poder lanzar y ayudar a construir una estación espacial
donde uno está a bordo de una creación de 45 toneladas
que va por el mundo a 5 millas por segundo,
8 kilómetros por segundo,
que da la vuelta al mundo 16 veces al día,
con experimentos a bordo que nos están enseñando
cuál es la sustancia que compone el universo
y haciendo 200 experimentos dentro.
Pero tal vez más importante aún,
es que nos permite ver el mundo de una manera
imposible por cualquier otro medio,
poder mirar hacia abajo
y si la mandíbula pudiera caerse lo haría,
la magnificencia asombrosa del orbe que gira debajo
como una galería de arte autopropulsada, de una belleza
fantástica en cambio constante que es el mundo en sí.
Y uno ve, dada la velocidad,
un amanecer o un atardecer cada 45 minutos
durante medio año.
Y la parte más hermosa de todo eso
es salir a dar una caminata espacial.
Uno está en una nave espacial unipersonal
que es el traje espacial,
y va por el espacio junto con el mundo.
Es una perspectiva totalmente diferente,
uno no está mirando hacia el universo.
La Tierra y uno juntos por el universo.
Y uno sostenido con una mano,
mira al mundo a su lado.
Un silencio ensordecedor
con color y textura conforme pasa
cautivante al lado de uno.
Si uno pudiera despegar los ojos de allí
y mirar bajo el brazo
hacia abajo todo lo demás,
hay una negrura insondable,
una textura de un espesor que uno siente que podría atravesar
y sostener con una mano
un vínculo con otros 7000 millones de personas.
Y yo estaba fuera en mi primera caminata espacial
cuando perdí la visión de mi ojo izquierdo,
y yo no sabía por qué.
De repente, mi ojo izquierdo se cerró de golpe
con un gran dolor
y yo no podía entender por qué mi ojo no estaba funcionando.
Pensaba: ¿y ahora qué hago?
Pensé, bueno, quizá por eso tenemos dos ojos,
y seguí trabajando.
Pero, por desgracia, sin gravedad
las lágrimas no caen.
Uno acaba teniendo una bola cada vez más grande de lo que sea
mezclada con las lágrimas del ojo
hasta que finalmente la bola es tan grande
que la tensión superficial la lleva por el puente de la nariz
como una diminuta cascada
que pasa al otro ojo
y ahora estaba completamente ciego
fuera de la nave espacial.
¿Qué es lo más aterrador para Uds.?
(Risas)
Quizá las arañas.
Mucha gente le teme a las arañas.
Creo que deberían tener miedo a las arañas;
las arañas son espeluznantes y tienen patas largas y peludas,
y arañas como ésta, la reclusa marrón,
es horrible. Si te pica una reclusa marrón
terminas con uno de estas grandes necrosis
en la pierna
y podría haber una ahora
en la silla detrás de Uds., de hecho.
¿Cómo saberlo?
Una araña cae sobre Uds.,
y les da un gran ataque espasmódico
porque las arañas son aterradoras.
Pero entonces Uds. podrían decir, bueno ¿hay una reclusa marrón
en la silla que está a mi lado o no?
No lo sé. ¿Hay reclusas marrones aquí?
Si investigan, descubrirán que
en el mundo hay unos 50 000 tipos diferentes de arañas,
y hay unas dos docenas que son venenosas
de las 50 000.
Y si están en Canadá, debido a los crudos inviernos
aquí en la C.B., hay unos 720, 730 tipos diferentes de arañas
y hay una -- una --
que es venenosa,
y su veneno ni siquiera es mortal,
es solo una picadura desagradable.
Y esa araña -- no solo esa --
pero esa tiene marcas hermosas,
dice: "Soy peligrosa, tengo símbolo de radiación"; es la viuda negra.
Si uno incluso tiene un poco de cuidado
puede evitar encontrarse con la araña
-- vive cerca del suelo --
si uno va caminando, nunca atravesará
una telaraña con una viuda negra que lo pique.
No construyen telarañas como esta,
las construye en las esquinas.
Y es la viuda negra porque
la hembra se come al macho;
nosotros no les importamos.
De hecho,
la próxima vez que pisen una telaraña,
no tienen que entrar en pánico y tener una reacción cavernícola.
El peligro es totalmente diferente al miedo.
¿Cómo moverse entonces?
¿Cómo cambiar el comportamiento?
Bueno, la próxima vez que vean una telaraña
vean bien, asegúrese de que no es una viuda negra,
y luego atraviésenla.
Y luego ven otra telaraña
y la atraviesan.
Es solo algo esponjoso. No es gran cosa.
Y la araña que puede aparecer no es una amenaza mayor que la de una mariquita
o una mariposa.
Les garantizo que si atraviesan 100 telas de araña
habrán cambiado
el comportamiento humano fundamental,
la reacción cavernícola,
y podrán caminar por el parque en la mañana
sin preocuparse por esa telaraña,
o por el ático de la abuela o lo que sea,
o por su propio sótano.
Y pueden aplicar esto a todo.
Si uno está fuera en una caminata espacial y queda ciego,
la reacción natural sería el pánico, pienso.
Sería ponerse nervioso y preocuparse.
Pero habíamos considerado todos los venenos,
y practicado con una variedad de telarañas.
Conocíamos todo lo que hay que saber
sobre trajes espaciales
y entrenamos bajo el agua miles de veces.
Y no solo practicamos las cosas que van bien,
practicamos cosas que salen mal todo el tiempo,
así que estamos contantemente atravesando esas telarañas.
Y no solo bajo el agua, sino también en laboratorios de realidad virtual
con el casco y los guantes
para sentir que es realista.
Así que cuando por fin realmente salimos en una caminata espacial,
se siente muy diferente que
si se tratara de la primera vez.
E incluso si uno está ciego
no ocurre la reacción natural de pánico.
En vez de eso, uno mira alrededor y dice:
"Bueno, no puedo ver,
pero puedo oír, puedo caminar,
Scott Parazynski está aquí conmigo.
Él podría venir en mi ayuda".
En realidad practicamos rescate de tripulación incapacitada,
así que podría llevarme como un dirigible
y meterme en la esclusa de aire si tuviera que hacerlo.
Podría abrirme mi propio camino de regreso.
No es algo tan grave.
Y, de hecho, si uno sigue lagrimeando durante un tiempo,
cualquier basura del ojo empieza a diluirse
y uno empieza a ver otra vez,
y Houston, si uno negocia con ellos,
ellos le permiten a uno seguir trabajando.
Terminamos toda la caminata espacial
y cuando regresamos adentro,
Jeff con un cotonete quitó la basura de mis ojos,
y resultó que era solo el antiniebla,
una mezcla de aceite y jabón, que me entró en el ojo.
Y ahora usamos No más lágrimas, de Johnson's
que probablemente deberíamos haber usado
desde el principio. (Risas)
Pero la clave de eso es
al mirar la diferencia
entre el peligro percibido y el peligro real
¿cuál es el riesgo real?
¿Cuál es la cosa real a la que uno debe tener miedo?
No un miedo genérico a que ocurran cosas malas.
Uno puede cambiar de manera fundamental su reacción a las cosas
de manera de poder llegar a lugares
y ver cosas y hacer cosas
que de otro modo nos estarían completamente negadas...
podía ver el sur del Sahara,
o la ciudad de Nueva York
de una manera de ensueño,
o la guinga inconsciente de los campos de Europa del Este
o los Grandes Lagos
como un conjunto de pequeños charcos.
Uno puede ver la falla de San Francisco
o la forma en que el agua pasa debajo del puente
totalmente diferente
de la forma que lo habría hecho
de no haber encontrado la manera de conquistar sus miedos.
Uno ve una belleza que de otro modo
nunca habría visto.
Es hora de volver a casa al final.
Esta es nuestra nave,
la pequeña Soyuz.
Subimos tres tripulantes,
y luego esta nave se separa de la estación
y cae a la atmósfera.
Estas dos partes
se derriten, se funden y se queman
en la atmósfera.
La única parte que sobrevive es la pequeña bala
en la que estamos montados,
y cae a la atmósfera,
y, básicamente,
estamos montando un meteorito de regreso a casa,
y montar meteoritos es aterrador,
y así debe ser.
Pero en vez de entrar a la atmósfera
gritando como uno lo haría
si de repente se encontrara montando un meteorito
de regreso a la Tierra (Risas)
en vez de eso, 20 años antes
empezamos a estudiar ruso,
y cuando aprendimos ruso,
aprendimos mecánica orbital en ruso,
y luego aprendimos teoría de control del vehículo,
y luego entramos al simulador
y practicamos una y otra y otra vez.
Y, de hecho, se puede volar este meteorito
y dirigirlo a la Tierra en un círculo de 15 kilómetros,
a cualquier lugar de la Tierra.
Por eso, cuando nuestra tripulación regresa
a la atmósfera en la Soyuz,
no gritamos, sino que reímos;
fue divertido.
Y cuando se abrió el gran paracaídas,
sabíamos que de no abrirse
hay un segundo paracaídas,
y funciona con un pequeño y buen mecanismo de relojería.
Así que regresamos, volvimos como un trueno,
a la Tierra y esta es la forma
de aterrizar en una Soyuz, en Kazajstán.
(Video) Periodista: Pueden ver uno de esos
helicópteros de búsqueda y recuperación, una vez más,
ese helicóptero es parte de una docena de helicópteros
rusos Mi-8.
Aterrizaje - 03:14 y 48 segundos,
a.m. Hora del Centro.
CH: Y uno rueda hasta detenerse
como si alguien tirara la nave de uno al suelo
y esta girase de punta a punta,
pero uno está listo para eso
en un asiento hecho a medida,
uno sabe cómo funciona el amortiguador.
Y entonces, finalmente, llegan los rusos,
te sacan,
te ponen en una silla,
y ahora uno puede mirar hacia atrás
a lo que fue una experiencia increíble.
Uno ha llevado los sueños de ese
niño de 9 años,
que eran imposibles
e intimidantemente aterradores,
intimidantemente temerarios,
y ponerlos en práctica,
e imaginar una forma de volver a autoprogramarse
para cambiar ese miedo ancestral
para que le permita a uno regresar
con un repertorio de experiencias y un nivel de inspiración
para otras personas
que nunca podrían haber sido posibles de otro modo.
Para concluir, me pidieron que toque la guitarra.
Conozco esta canción,
y es en realidad un tributo al genio
del propio David Bowie,
pero es también, pienso,
reflejo del hecho de que no somos máquinas
que exploran el universo;
somos personas,
y estamos tomando
esa capacidad de adaptación
y esa capacidad de comprensión
y la capacitad de llevar
nuestra propia autopercepción a un nuevo lugar.
(Música)